European union leaders have agreed to a
partial ban on Russian oil imports
that's the toughest sanctions imposed on
Russia since the invasion of Ukraine the
deal is the result of difficult
negotiations among member states that
ended in concessions to some EU
countries which are heavily dependent on
Russian oil
pumped from Russian Fields is no longer
welcome in most parts of the EU
EU leaders in Brussels reached an
unexpected breakthrough on the sixth
sanctions package just around midnight
Council should now be able to finalize a
ban on almost 90 percent of all Russian
oil imports by the end of the year the
Embargo a move that had been proposed by
the commission weeks ago and the
Ukrainian president had urged leaders to
finally make
Europe must show strength because only
Russia perceives power as an argument it
is time it is time for you to be not
separate not fragments but one whole
however member states are still not
entirely United on the issue the EU
plans to cut Russian oil transported by
sea only a concession made in order to
get Hungary on board
Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban
has formed close ties with Russia in the
past making the country heavily
dependent on Russian energy
Hungary will be able to continue to
receive oil by pipeline for now
the sanctions package also excludes
Russia's largest bank from the Swift
system bans three more Russian
state-owned broadcasters and sanctions
individuals responsible for war crimes
some leaders like the Latvian prime
minister have called to go even further
now
but opinions differ from its main
perspective from my perspective we
temporarily have reached our limits
definitely regarding sanctions that have
to do with energy
despite Hungary not playing along the
latest round of sanctions are believed
to be some of the most damaging measures
taken by the EU so far
a DW Brussels bureau chief Alexander
Phenom joins I mean Alexandra I bring
this into perspective for us how much of
a success is this ban
well the last three weeks uh were very
embarrassing for the European Union when
all this back and forth negotiating
arguing and we started to see first
cracks in the unity so now to see that
the European leaders were able to get
their act together that they were able
to push through the with this oil
embargo is a huge success when we take
into account that banning all petroleum
products and oil shipments would amount
to two-thirds of all Russian oil imports
to the European Union that is something
and we also have to consider that two
member states Poland and Germany have
already announced that they are going to
quit all Russian Imports by the end of
this year regardless of how they are
being transported to the European or to
those countries and that would amount to
90 of all Russian oil imports so this is
something that sounds like a lot what
kind of impact are these measures
expected to have on Russia overall
by buying Russian oil the European Union
puts around
260 million Europe's input is Putin's
pocket every day so this is a
significant amount of money of course we
have to consider that buying Russian gas
they are paying much more so that could
be should be the next step but we have
to say that that would be very difficult
to achieve an agreement here in the
European Union
now we just heard the Belgian prime
minister in our report there saying that
from his perspective the EU has
temporarily reached its limits regarding
energy sanctions what other sanctions
could the EU agree on
well I think that first of all we should
have a look at these six sanctions
package that was in principle approved
by the EU leaders here in Brussels and
that includes sanctions against the
largest Russian Banks Burbank that is
important they are going to Blacklist
military officials held responsible for
the atrocities in Butcher and other
towns in Ukraine and that could make a
difference this is a huge step and they
are already working on a seventh package
of sanctions planning to ban oil Russian
Imports but that remains to be seen how
quickly they can agree on that
UW Russell Spirit Chief Alexander
phenomenal thank you
and we are now joined by Mikhail
krutikin he's an oil and gas expert
currently based in Oslo in Norway
Michael how much is this partial Oil
Embargo really going to hurt Russia's
War Machine
well I think it is not just the war
machine but the Russian budget the
revenues of the Russian parts are going
to suffer if the Embargo goes into
effect in full force by the end of this
year I believe that the revenues of the
Russian budget will be less 25 at least
because it is not just the oil which
will stop flowing to Europe it will be a
refined project a petroleum product as
well and some of the Russian refineries
will have to seize operations as well as
oil producing sites and some companies
that service the oil and gas industry
will also lose their contracts this is a
tremendously large effect negative
effect on the Russian budget but the EU
has been discussing an oil embargo for
weeks didn't that give Russia time to
prepare for this
I do not think Russia has prepared for
anything there were just declarations
that the flow of oil instead of Europe
will go somewhere to China or India but
if we take a look at the transportation
routes to China they are food to their
filter to capacity you cannot add more
than maybe five million tons a year to
the 80 million tons a year that Russia
exports to China right now
and India is not going to absorb more
than six to seven million tons of oil
the volumes are microscopic if we can
compare them to the volume of crude oil
delivered to Europe it is about 20 about
110 million cubic meters a year so the
European ban is very and very sensitive
for us now the uh what impact will these
energy sanctions have on so the the
Russian population on the average
Russian
well we see that there will be uh first
uh unemployment
uh I uh receive reports from the oil and
gas producing areas in the north part of
western Siberia and some of the
settlements around produce and sites are
being depopulated people are just
go from their workplaces to somewhere
warmer climates in the central Russia
and unemployment is going to be
very strong
oil and gas expert Mikhail krutikian in
Oslo for us thank you very much
thank you